is small business saturday a time when  people are encouraged to shop local we  stopped by water street in henderson  today where city officials made a real  celebration out of it business leaders  were say their events there are  important because the area just doesn't  get as much attention  we're hoping to  get past the pandemic feel of everything  and bring life back to downtown i'd love  to see people just walking up and down  the street all hours of the day and  night like you see in all the other  places you know and right now we don't  have that  she says the pandemic hit local  businesses hard so they appreciate the  extra support from the city